okay here we in chapter five and the
labs on Cross validation and the
bootstrap um validating models is really
important um where you fit models on
separate training data and then you
evaluate it on test data or validation
data sets that uh that weren't involved
in the training and Jonathan's going to
show us how we do it in this slab thanks
Chev yes so uh one of the nice we're
going to be using pit learn sort of uh
cross validation
um setup which is one of the nice things
about psyched learn is for all of its
different models you can cross validate
them and almost the using almost the
same code we just have to swap out what
the particular estimator is so uh we'll
we'll in this in this lab we we'll look
at Cross validating um least squares
regression so we're going to compare
that with the uh the the train test
split that we saw in chapter 4 for
classification uh as well so those those
will be the the two things we look at
okay so um there are a few new Imports
so key Imports to look at are the uh
this kfold import that's going to be how
we Implement kfold cross validation the
cross validate function is that what
actually will be used to cross validate
the estimator um Le squares regression
and one small uh new import from islp
the ordinary Le squares regression we
saw in chapter 3 was actually from stats
models which is not part of psychic
learn so there's a little wrapper here
so we can cross validate the the stats
models using the same the psychic learn
sort of sort of formalism and as in
previous Labs we've put all the Imports
right at the beginning so it's very
clear what's needed to do the lab yes
that's sort of best practices felt in
Python because
well okay so we know what what is in in
the names space when we start okay so
let's run these cells because we'll have
to run them to run the code okay so we
use we're going to use the function
train test split that we saw in chapter
four to split our um in this case the
the auto data set where we try and
predict um miles per gallon as a
function of different features of the
car we're going to split um the the data
set of size 392 we're going to split
into two equal size data sets of size
196 um and we'll do as we did in chapter
four we're going to fit the Le squares
regression on the training data
set um and then we're going to evaluate
um the mean squared error on the the
validation or the test data set um so
this uh hpmm that's our model spec or
model
Matrix Constructor and it will construct
the design Matrix for the validation uh
this is the response for the validation
or or test data and we're just going to
find the predicted
values and compute the MSE
so
our uh estimated SM is
23.62 so we might um this was just using
horsepower as a linear term we might
want to use something like train test
split to to pick an an order of
polinomial like in the in the
classification chapter um we um we used
it to compare different different models
but here we have the model is the order
of the polinomial so we're going to make
a little Loop
um in order to compute the msse for a
few different orders of polinomial so
here's a little helper function to help
us encapsulate what we did above for the
train and test split uh that we'll use
to evaluate in a for Loop this is uh the
first example in the lab we've seen of a
for Loop uh we're going to construct our
model spec on different polinomial of
different degrees of horsepower and
we're going to store the results u in
the msse
vector
okay so we see for the linear effect uh
23 and we see a pretty big Improvement
going to quadratic and less Improvement
going going further so there's really
not much of a gain it seems to be going
from quadratic to cubic in fact it looks
like it's a loss yes in this case yes
and of course there's no guarantee that
on the test data it would be an
improvement but on the training data of
course we know it's an improvement
so this is on the validation
data yes this is we we've trained on the
training data using the same split for
every degree and then evaluate it on the
validation data okay and of course for
different splits we chose one split into
50/50 there's many different splits into
50/50 we might get slightly different
answers so we're going to change the
random seed a bur above the random seed
was Zero I think doesn't really matter
what it is here's a different one and
we'll rerun the same code and we see we
get qualitatively similar results of
course but the numbers are different uh
the the linear one has an MSE of 20.7
instead of 23.6 or
so okay so that Val there that
variability we saw in uh in the in test
train split is related to the actual
splitting into the two halves and
there's some Randomness involved in that
and also Jonathan we split our data set
which isn't that big to start with into
two pieces and so now we got half the
data is used for training and half for
testing doesn't seem a good use of of
the data right and so you're going to
tell us about cross validation how you
can do it more
efficiently uh and get bigger training
data sets in the process yes that's
right for every split into 50/50 the
actual estimator has half the data set
uh to work with um and cross validation
is a method for instance Lea one out
cross validation every estimator there
has 391 data points instead of 196 so
the estimators are better and it's a
slightly different estimator because
it's trained on more data but it also um
it also reduces some of the variability
you see in in Split to split uh in class
validation because it uses every data
point gets treated as a a test
Point okay so as I mentioned above uh py
learn has a very nice way uh to cross
validate many many different estimators
that's this cross validate
function okay so let's just um look at
our first example of cross validation
we're going to cross validate in the
regression model with just a linear
effect for horsepower so this sklearn
orsm is a wrapper that takes a method
from a fitting method from stats models
in this case ordinarily squares and uh a
way a design or model spec and creates
something that Sid learn is fam familiar
with and that pych learn can use for
cross
validation so the main uh function in
this in this chunk here is this cross
validate function here so it uh takes
this is an estimator that pyit learn is
aware of it takes uh a set of features
and a response and then an argument
about how to do cross validation here
and here I've given it the number of
rows in Auto dot shape so this is n Fold
cross validation also called leave1 out
cross validation oh so order do shape
zero is the number of rows that's right
yes and so if CV equals N means you're
going to
have leave one out cross validation
unfold cross validation yes that's right
so this this model HP model will be fit
n times each time with n minus one data
points
okay so if that's pretty quick yes
computers are pretty fast these
days uh so if we wanted to change this
to tenfold cross validation one of the
nice things about SK learn is we just
changed the method of this argument we
passed to to cross validation so let's
skip down to
that
um so I this one here is 10-fold cross
validation so we're going to this object
here CV I've called it it's it's going
to be kfold with 10 splits
um this the shuffle equals in random s
equals z that's just to make sure that
it's a random one if without these it
just takes breaks it into 10 uh you know
regular space but that that's neither
here nor there really okay so
um so now when we pass this CV argument
uh to cross validate it will only do fit
10 models each time with roughly you
know 90% of 392 whatever that is you
know roughly 350 data points and one of
the other thing we've done here is we'
made a for Loop to cross Val validate
for every different power up to up to
fifth order powers of
horsepower
uh what's happened is I've skipped ahead
without running all the code necessary
so let me just run all the code up to
here and run that again okay so now we
get as a function of the uh the degree
we have this cross validation estimate
and note these are pretty similar to
what we had for the test and sprain test
and train split uh but and the same
pattern of no improvement going Beyond
quadratic uh for for the the degree of
the
polinomial okay so you can also do test
and train similarly with cross
validation uh using this thing called
this instead of kfold this thing called
Stuffle split but we'll leave that for
you to do um
offline